Speaker 1: All right, let's hear from a few
more people, the way we now take phone calls
is really through the Internet. Voice over IP
technology David Pakman dotcom discord is where
you can find it. Let's go next to Kelsey from
Colorado. Kelsey, you're on the air. Hi, David.
How are you? I'm doing well, Kelsey. Thank you.
Speaker 4: Welcome back to the United States.
Thank you, sir. I have a quick question for you.
I wrote this down. It seems the country is pretty
progressive on some issues, like poll after poll
shows that big issues like infrastructure, mass
mandates, health care, et cetera, have a lot of
support from both sides. What's it going to take
for the opposition not to dictate the shooting
down of this of the support of these policies?
Speaker 1: Well, that this this is one you've
come across here, Kalsi, one of the great
injustices and corrupt elements of our political
system, which is that we supposedly are electing
officials to represent our views. But in reality,
our elected officials at the federal level are
well to the right of the American public.
If you compare American support for abortion
being mostly legal to support in the House
and Senate for abortion being mostly legal.
There's a disconnect in the Senate and House
are much more against abortion than the people.
And it goes to many of the other issues. You're
talking about basic access to health care,
pick whatever issue you want. So there's
a number of different reasons for this.
One is gerrymandering, right? So that you have
people in districts that are drawn in such a way
that a lot of liberals are sort of crammed into
districts where they win those districts by a lot,
and then you have much more competitive
districts where Republicans barely win.
And so you've got a whole bunch of people who
have the views you're pointing out, but they
are underrepresented because of gerrymandering.
That's like one thing. The other thing also is
that in general, corporations and rich people's
desires through the money they contribute are
way more likely to be made law and to be listened
to by our elected officials then just like the
average person. And so you stack all these things
on top of each other and you end up with the
situation we have, which is you look at an issue,
66 percent support among the American public, only
52 percent support among our elected officials.
And it is a problem. I don't know how we fix it.
Speaker 4: It's just really frustrating
looking at all these polls, and it's like
false hope almost, because it's like, oh, well,
not everything is as it seems that, you know,
you get to see on the TV or reading and
media all the time. Yeah. But then again,
you have all those other issues that you mentioned
that prevents anything from moving forward,
which is incredibly frustrating. So it's a
really weird kind of middle ground to be in.
Speaker 1: Absolutely. Absolutely. And let's
let's keep working on this issue. Kelsey,
it's not going away anytime soon.
Speaker 4: Great. Well, thanks for
your time, David. Really appreciate
Speaker 1: it. My pleasure. Thank
you for your call. Pretty close to a
perfect phone call. I mean, audio worked,
got right into the subject matter. Really
not not a lot to complain about there